In Season 5 of The Wire, Gus, a newspaper
editor says this.
This is an ethos that The Wire takes to heart
and uses to develop it’s themes and ideas.
As I laid out in part 1 of this series on
The Wire, show creators David Simon and Ed
Burns, had intentions for the show that went
far beyond creating entertainment.
They were interested in “what feels true”
and they used moments to examine and develop
their themes.
In this video I’m going to show how the
wire uses narrative structure, and the juxtaposition
and relationship of scenes and characters
to illustrate ideas.
To do this, I’ll have to spoil aspects of
the show.
If you haven’t seen the show yet, and you’d
like a spoiler free overview of why it’s
great, make sure to watch part one in this
series.
All in the Game: The Wire’s Message
The Wire deals with many issues, but it’s
primary focus is illustrating the city of
Baltimore by showing its various institutions,
and the individuals that make up those institutions.
The show portrays how economic, political
and individual motivations affect how institutions
operate.
Key to the story is how these motivations
keep the institutions in a cycle of failure,
and make it difficult for individuals to reform.
But how do you lay these ideas out on film?
How do you portray them without beating your
audience over the head with preachy, complicated
exposition?
One way is to use the technique that Gus describes.
You show individual moments, and use the relationship
between moments in different character’s
lives to infer certain ideas.
Here’s an example, early in season 2 there
are two scenes that mirror each other visually
and in content.
Stinger Bell and Avon Barksdale communicate
through the chainlink fence of a prison.
Daniels and McNulty communicate through the
chainlink of the evidence room.
The conversations in the two scenes are different
in how the relate to the story, but It illustrates
the dysfunction of the police department,
who is punishing the officers that successfully
arrested Avon Barksdale.
None of this is in exposition.
The Wire doesn’t tell you these two institutions
are similar, it just lets you see that they
are.
The idea is simply established through context
and the visual of the two chain link fences.
Through these kinds of associations the show
creates the City of Baltimore as a character.
Each institution and character touches every
other in some way.
Shifting an aspect of one, affects the others,
the failure of one, makes the success of another
less likely.
Corner kids will take money that’s being
given away, just like Clay Davis
Clay davis is told he shouldn’t flip and
needs to carry the charge against him, just
like Deangelo is told the same thing.
Deangelo is scolded for being unloyal to his
family, just like Carver is scolded for being
unloyal to his police unit.
Carver is also scolded for going outside the
chain of command, while Carcetti later thanks
Daniels for doing the same thing.
Carcetti is trying to do politics differently
but struggles against the cons of Clay Davis,
just like Stringer Bell does when trying to
reform his drug empire.
Stringer Bell is punished by his institution
for that very attempt to reform, just like
Bunny Colvin for his attempt to reform.
Bunny Colvin reaches for a hairbrained illegal
scheme to try to force reform when all else
fails, which is mirrored by McNulty’s hairbrained
illegals scheme to inspire change in season
5.
McNulty’s actions in season 5 lead to him
losing what he loves, Police work, just like
Marlow’s mistakes lead to him losing what
he loves, his reputation.
Even though Marlow tries to reform, he’s
drawn back to the streets, Just like Avon
Barksdale was after an attempt to reform.
Avon Barksdale is more interested in sending
a message than in effectiveness, just like
Police Commissioner Burrell.
This is just a fraction of the ways that characters
and moments are interconnected on The Wire.
Doing this provides some of the context necessary
to seriously examine the issues.
Separate individuals are also used to tell
aspects of a broader more general story.
A great example of this is Deangelo and Denis
Cutty.
Deangelo is on a path to reform.
But he’s killed before he has time to complete
this arc.
Killing off Deangelo is necessary to illustrate
the forces that keep reform from happening.
But what if he had made it out of prison alive.
What would that have looked like?
The Wire provides us with Denis Cutty.
Who illustrates what Deangelo’s path might
have looked like had he lived.
There’s an amazing amount of nuance that’s
available with this type of storytelling.
It’s one of the ways The Wire balances precariously
on the edge of cynicism and hope.
Seeing Deangelo die is heartbreaking.
Getting to see Cutty successfully reform provides
a ray of hope.
But even then, the struggles of reforming
are made very clear.
This technique of relating characters allows
the show to cover much more ground and give
far more context than it would normally be
able to in only five linear seasons.
Another example of this are characters Jimmy
McNulty and Kima Greggs.
We meet McNulty in season 1 as a talented
but dysfunctional detective.
He has a drinking problem, has trouble keeping
relationships together, and is jaded by his
career.
Kima’s arc over the entire show, helps to
illustrate how Jimmy ended up how he was in
Season 1.
By doing this The Wire tells the individual
stories of Jimmy McNulty and Kima Greggs,
but it’s also telling the broader story
of the “Jaded, dysfunctional detective.”
It tells the individual story of Deangelo
Barksdale and Denis Cutty, but the broader
story of “reformed gangster.”
It tells the individual story of Micheal and
Omar Little, but the broader story of “stickup
man”
Ultimately the story of the kids and seasons
4 and 5 are the largest piece of this inter-character
narrative.
By showing each kid’s struggles and what
leads them to their final destinations, we
see how characters like Omar, Bubbles and
Bunny Colvin might have come to be.
It allows us to connect the failure of the
school system to the dysfunction of the institutions
in season 1-3.
But the show isn’t so deterministic as to
say that the individual adhering to the broader
story is inevitable.
Through great effort, some individuals can
break out of the cycle and behave differently.
Unfortunately though, it often takes great
trauma to inspire an individual to reform.
This is illustrated in Season 4 through Bubbles
and Nehman.
Two characters that successfully reform.
Their reform is inspired by painful events.
It’s the Wire’s call for individual reform,
but also an insinuation that, similarly true
reform for institutions may only come through
trauma to the institution.
And understanding this broader narrative about
institutions helps us understand why a character
like Omar is so compelling in the show.
In a world where so many characters are bound
or hobbled by the failing institutions around
them, a true rogue, a lone rebel, is someone
we can root for.
But all this is left for the audience to extrapolate
for themselves from individual moments, which
keeps the show from feeling like it’s shoving
a message down your throat.
There are layers to unravel, and depths to
examine and interpret.
The show allows you to use your worldview
to see the issues it’s laying out, even
as it might challenge your own assumptions
and worldview, and present its own.
In the final part of this Series I’ll be
examining more layers of the onion, and showing
why each season of the wire is important
to the story.